[Applauso]
li vedete bene ok ma io non vedo voi e
soprattutto non vedo il bordo del palco
quindi fatemi mettere giù questo bel
nastro che mi sono portato così eccolo
lì così evita di cadere in braccio alle
signore della prima fila anche se so che
sarebbe quello che vogliono
ok ecco questa è la posizione una
malattia tra tra visione e cecità quindi
riesco a vedere quella luce lì in fondo
ma ripeto non vedo le signore in prima
fila che sono sicuramente bellissime
però questa è la visione e soprattutto
non non riesco a distinguere bene le
figure nel quando è buio e non riesco a
leggere le pagine di un libro però
riuscirei per esempio a raccogliere il
nastro che ho appena appoggiato per
terra senza esitare
ecco è come guardare il mondo attraverso
una telecamera bassa risoluzione come le
prime sono state realizzate oppure come
guardare il mondo attraverso il buco di
una serratura infatti gli inglesi la
chiamano chi vuol visione la malattia
che nel mio caso porta a questa visione
tubolare a questa visione notturna molto
ridotta
si chiama retinite pigmentosa è una
malattia appunto una delle possibili
cause di l'ipovisione in questo caso si
tratta di una malattia genetica però le
cause che possono portare all'ipovisione
possono essere tante possono essere
anche di dovuto un incidente in questo
caso si tratta di una malattia
ereditaria però la spiga non viene mai
da sola quindi a me hanno dato anche
l'ipocrisia e la combinazione di queste
due limitazioni sensoriali prende il
nome di sindrome di usher che è una
malattia che compare negli elenchi delle
malattie rare
quindi a me è stata diagnosticata
all'età di 17 anni però è stato solo
quando ne avevo più o meno 19 che ho
cominciato a percepire il trauma della
degenerazione perché ho cominciato a
veramente a la degenerazione cominciato
a fare il suo corso e quindi ho
cominciato a ha cominciato a fare il suo
corso come ho cominciato a percepire
questa sorta di condanna al buio e
quindi l'emozione ragazzi ai che mi
scorre il tempo questa sorta di al buio
però è stato solo nel 2011 poi che ho
attuato una sorta di cambio di
prospettiva quindi che ho cominciato a
cambiare l'attitudine quindi di quello
che posso fare
invece su quello che non posso più fare
ecco è questo cambio di prospettiva l'ho
portato avanti soprattutto durante un
workshop che ho messo in piedi a berlino
nel 2013 e dove il tema principalmente
era il tema dell'accessibilità ora già
vedete alle mie spalle delle immagini
che riguardano degli elementi urbani
perché se ci pensate gli elementi urbani
sono sempre sui toni del grigio del
grigio su grigio quindi i pali della
luce che sono metallici piuttosto che i
panettoni i paracarri è tutto sempre sui
toni del grigio grigio quindi per gli
ipovedenti questo rende molto difficile
l'individuazione di questi elementi che
sono tra l'altro gli elementi che
caratterizzano le città però nel mio
caso sono sono ostacoli per ipovedenti
sono degli ostacoli
ecco allora che qui colorarli di giallo
sarebbe un modo per renderli più
accessibili più facili da individuare e
quindi magari con la giusta combinazione
anche più belli le città potrebbero
essere anche più belle con questa nuova
tonalità di colore
ecco sì però questo questo e questo è
uno dei modi che questo questo modo di
ingiallire il mondo quindi yellow the
world è una campagna che ho cercato di
iniziare per cominciare ad ingiallire il
mondo
e con questa idea in testa nel 2015 ha
detto ma sai cosa io questa ondata di
giallo che invade il mondo me la voglio
gustare dall'alto e qual è il posto più
alto del mondo deve andare a osservare
questa ondata di giallo che invade il
mondo
il monte everest e così con questa in
the in testa nel 2015
ho cominciato a a preparare questo
viaggio in una preparazione sia mentale
e psicologica che fisica
nel marzo del 2015 sono partito per per
kathmandu
da lì ho preso un velivolo che atterra a
lukla che è una cittadina 2800 metri che
vi posso garantire che so già questo
aeroporto è molto temibile insomma
perché è una pista inclinata che finisce
a strapiombo sulla valle e quindi già
quell'aeroporto è stata una sorta di
inizio non poco non poco rassicura non
molto rassicurante però da lì è
cominciata questa escursione e ho
camminato per giorni
parte il video eccolo qui parte il video
che quindi ha dominato per giorni e io
vedo solo al centro in questa visione
tubolare a serratura che vi raccontavo
prima e quindi ogni piccolo ostacolo
ogni sasso ogni masso diventa quasi una
difficoltà insormontabile e devo se
dovevo sempre osservare i piedi della
guida che camminava di fronte a me e in
alcuni casi è stato veramente
impegnativo perché ho camminato anche di
notte in alcune occasioni e soprattutto
a meno 20 gradi con le falangi delle
dita che si che si ghiacciano con labbra
l'acqua nella borraccia che è anche
quella sì ghiacciava nel giro di cinque
minuti quindi delle condizioni non molto
semplici che si sommano a questa visione
molto ridotta che quindi rende difficili
anche i passi durante il giorno
ecco però potete immaginare che tutta
questa fatica a un certo punto è stata
ripagata da l'arrivo al campo base che
sono riuscito a conquistare rendendolo
in qualche modo più giallo ho piantato
questa sorta di segno di riconoscimento
e il 25 marzo 2015
sono arrivato al campo base dell'everest
yellow debord bridge ben 5.300 del
momento
per il momento è tutto quello che ha da
dire dicevo allora con il 25 il 25 marzo
[Applauso]
grazie però appunto come dicevo le 360
gradi di panorama che si dipanavano di
fronte ai miei occhi quando mentre erano
nella palestra mi immaginavo queste
montagne che poi sono riuscito a vedere
per quanto appunto con quella
risoluzione un po ridotta è un'immagine
che si che ripaga di tutta la fatica ma
non ci si improvvisa avventurieri quindi
il discorso è l'avventura comincia molti
anni prima
ve ne racconto racconto alcune tappe
questo è la tappa del attraversamento
dell'outback australiano a bordo di un
furgoncino a dir poco scassato ho fatto
nel 2004 altre avventure sono state
quelle del del cammino di santiago 2007
ho camminato da sony jam piede poi in
france in francia fino al confine con
della spagna fino a finistère sulla
costa dell'atlantico 800 chilometri che
ho percorso a piedi da solo anche in
quell'occasione sembrano cose di tutti i
giorni con questi difficoltà visive e
uditive sono una comunque una conquista
qui sono al machu picchu che ho
raggiunto percorrendo l'inca trail
passando anche in quell'occasione aic
ritoccando i 5.000 metri ai piedi del
monte sull cantai ma l'altra grande
avventura che invece ho fatto quella
bordo di questa vascello di ferro
cemento si chiama iraq litus una barca
di oltre 40 anni che ha solcato tutti i
mari e a bordo di questo vascello io ho
percorso ho vissuto a bordo di questo
paciello per due anni partendo dalla
dall'africa eccomi qui con i bambini del
mozambico con quale ha fatto alcune
attività di volontariato in un
orfanatrofio e da qui sono partito e ho
attraversato l'oceano l'oceano atlantico
per arrivare fino a rio de janeiro poi
costeggiare tutte le
la costa del sud america fino a arrivare
al mar dei carabi fino a cuba ecco città
del capo
havana un'infinità di miglia se ci penso
adesso quasi non mi viene non mi viene
da crederci però cosa succede in questo
mare sempre piatto è uguale a se stesso
che il sole almeno nell'attraversamento
del genoa tra antico sorge alle tue
spalle e tramonta di fronte a te tutti i
giorni uguale a se stesso in un ambiente
che sostanzialmente non cambia mai anche
se la barca in un ambiente in costante
movimento
il panorama intorno a te è sempre uguale
un orizzonte piatto con questo sole che
costantemente ti ricorda il ciclo del
giorno
in questo panorama che non muta non
cambia mai cosa succede succede accade
una trasformazione che tu non sai
riconoscere fino a quando arrivi
sull'altra sponda
si siede sulla sedia di un barbiere ti
fa radere la barba e ti accorgi che
sotto quella barba c'è la pelle bruciata
dal sole dal vento che l'immagine della
trasformazione e allora è stato lì che
mi sono accorto che era cambiato
qualcosa proprio al sull'altra sponda
aveva trovato una trasformazione che è
quella che per me è servita a spostare
quel focus che vi dicevo prima e quindi
a quella andare oltre i limiti oltre
quei confini che sono il contenitore
oltre i quali invece espandere i sogni
le passioni i desideri
ecco se questi sono i limiti che ci
definiscono ai suoi voi ci pensate
tutti noi siamo fatti di limiti siamo
fatti di limiti che sono quelli fisici o
figurati di cui è fatto il nostro
carattere perché se ci pensate
siamo simpatici nella misura di quanto
di quello che diciamo o di quello che
non diciamo del nostro cinismo magari
siamo altruisti nella misura di quello
che facciamo per gli altri o che non
facciamo per gli altri
siamo rispettosi nella misura di quello
che facciamo per l'ambiente le persone o
le cose ecco tutti questi elementi del
nostro carattere sono definiti dai dei
limiti dai dei contorni dai dei peri da
un perimetro dicevo anche quelli fisici
magari nel mio caso
che definire quali sono i miei limiti
qui vedo qui non vedo qui vedo qui non
vedo oppure quello che non sento per
esempio il suono di un campanello di un
telefono non lo sento quello di un
trombone invece lo sento quindi è facile
capire quali sono questi limiti però
sono proprio quelli che mi hanno spinto
poi a cercare di andare oltre di capire
come potevo cercare di vincerle e quindi
di trasformare di seguire le passioni di
seguire i desideri perché se mi fossi
fermato a quello che non vedo questo
punto non dovrei neanche scendere da
quella scaletta dopo perché non lo vedo
però c'è sempre un sistema per cambiare
allora io non ho la pretesa che questo
sia una storia necessariamente che sia
di ispirazione ma bastano delle volte
una scintilla un qualcosa che vi fa
scoccare dentro un'idea un suono nuovo
un colore nuovo e allora da oggi magari
il giallo è il colore di chi vuole
provare ad andare oltre di chi vuole
provare a trasformare le proprie
passioni
ecco che allora quel taker di cui
dicevamo prima e diventa un prendersi
cura dei sogni
e allora cosa c'entrano i sogni con i
marciapiedi
cosa c'entrano i pali della luce con le
passioni
il giallo forse diventa oggi il comune
denominatore di questo panorama insolito
e diventa la traduzione cromatica di
quel baker vuol dire prendiamoci cura
dei sogni prendiamoci cura di noi
grazie
[Applauso]